voilà l'hiver cousine qui on l'a pris un
tout à l'heure va réunir aujourd'hui en
urgence son conseil de sécurité un
réunion imminente nous dit on du côté du
kremlin vladimir poutine il prendra la
parole gauthier rybinski bonjour
beaucoup d'informations dévoilées ce
matin par par le cre et les mains le
kremlin et toujours cette même
rhétorique qui met en avant des
provocations côté ukrainien on vient
d'ailleurs d'apprendre il ya quelques
instants qu'un obus ukrainien aura
détruit un poste frontière russe aurait
puisque c'est la partie russe qui
communiquent évidemment et on sait ce
genre d'événement est un argument rêvée
pour la partie russe pour intervenir en
territoire ukrainien
rim en rêvait mais dont on ne peut pas
préjuger pour l'instant qu'elle sera
j'allais dire la pente où le versant qui
l'a qu'il embrasse pourquoi parce que
comme vous le dites c'est un argument
rêvée pour intervenir mais ça peut être
aussi pour vladimir poutine ça dépend de
ce qu'il a en tête mais ça peut être
aussi un moyen de dire vous voyez nous
subissons des provocations sur le
terrain l'armée russe subi des
provocations mais moi je garde le sang
froid moi je n'interviens pas moi je
suis un dirigeant responsable
contrairement aux américains et aux
occidentaux qui crient au loup en
permanence qui font de la surenchère sur
l'information moi je suis un dirigeant
de sang-froid responsable mur et je
n'interviens pas et je contiens ma
colère vous voyez les deux sont
possibles c'est ça d'ailleurs qui pose
problème non seulement à ceux qui
commentent mais aussi aux dirigeants
c'est de dire de quel côté ça peut
pencher et les deux sont plausibles il
n'y a pas de façon de de différencier
les deux juste une chose sur le sur le
même domaine quand vladimir poutine ou
le kremlin fait savoir aujourd'hui que
il est prématuré d'organiser un sommet
avec joe biden alors qu éventuellement
hier alors ça on n'est pas dans le
secret de la diplomatie française
éventuellement hier lundi le kremlin a
dit oui accord de principe ça sert à
quoi par rapport à cette guerre de
l'information où l'occident en mettant
la barre très haut c'est à dire en
suscitant un affolement volontaire
moscou a été en quelque sorte j'allais
dire dépassé dans ce domaine là moscou
aime bien avoir la maîtrise de
l'information et en premier hélas ce que
fait la dîme et recousus ça peut être
aussi une manière de récupérer les rênes
la maîtrise de l'information disant
'vous voyez vous emballez sur un sommet
éventuelles nous on n'est pas d'accord
pour l'instant l'emballement
l'emballement occidentales et les
américains qui s'appuie notamment sur ce
genre de clichés on va les voir
peut-être à l'écran washington qui a dit
redouter une invasion dans l'est dans
les prochaines heures s'appuie notamment
sur ses dernières images satellites
capter hier à aso lotis par une une
société américaine vous allez les voir
images prises à une quinzaine de
kilomètres seulement de la frontière
ukrainienne on y aperçoit le déploiement
supplémentaire de soldats russes
l'arrivée aussi de nouveaux blindés les
voilà ces images ici ce qui confirme
l'hypothèse d'un déploiement
supplémentaire de troupes d'appareils
aussi milité à ce qui contredit
l'argumentaire russes de dire voilà on
calme le jeu on se retire oui mais là
encore un autre une autre version est
possible vous avez parfaitement raison -
c'est ça le problème ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure on on ne peut pas
distinguer le vrai du faux mais l'autre
possibilité l'autre explication possible
c'est qu'évidemment les russes savent
très bien que ces images satellitaires
voix et capte ce qui se passe sur le
terrain quand on veut faire pression par
on montre que ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et réel massif en ordre de
bataille donc évidemment si on veut
faire pression la russie a tout intérêt
à montrer le plus possible des colonnes
de chars de bhl des deux troupes de
fantassins se déployant partir de là la
menace est plausible
il faut quand même relevé dans cette
histoire c'est que
parallèlement à ce que vous disiez et à
l'utilisation de ces images si
l'occident avait de réelles intentions
belliqueuses à l'endroit de moscou il
n'y aurait pas besoin d'instaurer ou de
planter des missiles à la frontière
ukrainienne ukraino russe il suffirait
de les mettre dans l'ouest de la france
aux pays bas au royaume uni les missiles
de moyenne portée vont très facilement
jusqu'à moscou donc la menace
occidentale elle serait là encore vous
l'a dit mir poutine qu'est ce qui dit il
dit je ne veux pas d'une menace
occidental je ne veux pas de l'otan à
mes portes y compris même aux portes de
l'union européenne puisqu'il dit qu'il
faut retirer de pologne les pays baltes
les missiles oui mais alors dans ce cas
ci c'est pas une question militaire
c'est bien une question politique et la
question politique qui gêne la dit
mi-août insee de voir ses marges les
confins de l'ancien empire soviétique
passer progressivement à la démocratie
c'est le cas en ukraine ça pourrait être
le cas en géorgie si loukachenko a été
renversé en biélorussie ça pourrait être
le cas et ça c'est insupportable
pourquoi parce non seulement il est
convaincu de la justesse de son régime
et de la verticalité autoritaire du
pouvoir mais il est aussi convaincu
d'une chose très précise c'est que si
ces pays était gagné par une vraie
démocratisation et bien il y aurait un
risque de contagion démocratique pour la
population et cécilia de contagion
démocratique le régime de poutine ne
servira plus à rien on en revient donc
toujours à cette même préoccupation à sa
perte ou non d'un fluence merci beaucoup
gauthier ans pour le décryptage